n'oubliez pas non plus ne pas baisser la
tête que vous dansez sinon vous êtes
tout le temps comme ça
et du coup le public ivoirien donc lever
la tête
n'oubliez pas de sourire doux sourire
que vous avez envie d'accord plus que
quelques heures avant le spectacle
ces jeunes viennent des différents
quartiers de châteauroux il ne pratique
pas la danse pendant le reste de l'année
leur professeur de hip hop doit donc
s'adapter à leur niveau je leur donne
des passes simples mais pas baser qu'en
débutant ce qu'on apprend pour les
enfants de 7 à 11 ans et du coup je
réussis alors monté une petite
chorégraphie mais sur une musique rapide
en fait ce n'est pas très simple et sûre
de la musique rapide
pour les motiver parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pas passer pour des jeunes qui
font jamais dedans ça
durant toute l'année pardon donc il faut
vraiment les motiver faut les pousser
faut les emmener loin
depuis une semaine ils répètent tous les
matins leur petite chorégraphie sur la
musique de bio ses placements
enchaînement départ respect des tempes
même s'ils ne sont pas forcément fan de
rap les ados arrive à tenir le rythme et
les coureurs sont assez simples et ils
donnent bien le rythme et ses essais f1
c'est bien c'est très tendance bien quoi
c'est une petite angoisse pour ce soir
non parce que c'est la troisième année
le fait pas j'ai l'habitude les pas de
danse y sont des fois ils ont un peu
compliqué mais là au bout d'une semaine
c'est bon vous a dans la tête ligne puis
7 ans mini bus qu'ils rejoignent la
cantine pour la pause déjeuner le repas
est vite avalé car c'est déjà l'heure de
leur cours de percussions twilight
en quelques heures les jeunes ont réussi
à prendre spontanément quelques rythmes
simples grâce aussi au talent de leur
professeur john boswell de même je pense
pas que l'idée leur viennent ça peut
être justement une façon de devenir
alaoui pop
aux percussions et c'est les
opportunités une partie du prix de ce
stage est pris en charge par la ville la
semaine coûte entre 20 et 50 euros par
enfant des subventions qui permettent
une réelle initiation et d'élargir leurs
horizons
je n'avais jamais fait j'aime bien en
faire pourquoi parce qu'on s'amuse on
fait des trucs un solo c'est facile non
certes tous ne deviendront pas musiciens
ou danseurs professionnels
mais tout d'un coup les vacances sont
devenus passionnante